oh sure in the submission called the
molecular level hey hey I know you're
not here for me I can't get out not on
my own I'm going to have to trust you to
help me I promise I guess I don't ok the
password in a toolbox over there use it
to gain access can I just hack it
ya bin this match okay okay
I don't know what to say don't say
anything just get out of here okay
that's cool I thing in here good I can't
get that strong yeah you take of all
over [ __ ] around hey there please
don't hurt me generally from me excuse
me
oh [ __ ]
let's get the [ __ ] out of here that's
fat man up there
good okay let's get the [ __ ] out of here
how are y'all come I know what suit
yourself but just sit yourself
you have [ __ ] I get out of here can't
remember
there we go
okay thank God hello sir tinker Tom's
been looking for you I have a report
here it reads more like a comic book
apparently one hell of a fight took
place at greentech genetics all right Oh
what have you heard one of our agents
took a coarser alone and that agent is
you I'm all for one hmm do you know
anything about decoding of course or
chip you have one of their chips yeah
[ __ ] her panties are white as [ __ ] here
where's dared to much nitroglycerin
Thank guys crazy hey coding a course or
chip is a very delicate operation a
million things can go long the least of
which is losing the data fortunately we
have the right man for the job hey did
you need something tom we got a cursor
chip whoa for you call mr. ages you've
hit the judgment ages hand over the chip
let's see what's on it
here you go all right just had the
circuit analyzer take effect you yes dad
if he is your crush was shattered why
not take this don't crash memory hiccup
you got what if it takes the reservoir
with us all right money to [ __ ] here
things are quiet Oh they've added more
Dustin so that's like this is gonna be
come on baby show me that pattern where
is it wait they're using the same
logarithmic function as the key
generator got you you Institute bastard
I got you mm-hmm Cahill them to let me
know mission specs before the dead drop
show me tits just once then we got it we
got the code okay let me load that onto
the hollow tape boy yeah good work des
has given me clearance to set up my
atmospherics jennifer jo
tick hut at tech cluttered you from one
of those balls you got too many teeth to
be a scammer okay okay okay somebody the
same here let's say here ok wasn't sure
I'd see you again sets off knocked out I
have the cup suppose I who did get word
juma the railroad no good I would have
expected Lee sorry care of you I did the
best I cry came up with some schematics
for you how's the symbol explanation I
know the craziest part of the design
that classical all the daters on her
money I want to be clear that can have
her it'll work for the ring but if you
can build this to [ __ ] can you climb hmm
kind of carrot that I got it back I
don't you for its my own meal no go on
talk to the Minutemen Brotherhood or
railroad okay okay that's dead let's
let's do this
okay let's do this
Tom watch for something sorry tinker
Tom's got me doing the Mona
okay take your time where ya where ya
brother there he is this my man [ __ ]
stock up hand over the plans this big
hey yeah there you go some key with Wow
molecular you can buy vert the signal
using ahead can you have alt and you
build it the plans cover all behind eh
this video the stabilized reflect the
platform by the time you next a foe we
can scrounge up the patrol where the
field I know Pam was running numbers on
a good site for a new safe once you set
up the safe out or you could do your ok
bill that now that talk to pam a musher
station oh [ __ ] is pam has arrived I
have a mission for you without
increasing efficiency of synth traffic
flow arts of entire organization being
compromised increase daily solution a
new distribution center ok cached
they're gonna be pacified the target
located
ok let's do it that's let's do this sada
oh okay guess we're gonna do this first
actually [ __ ] tough [ __ ] ok I'll use a
farm this is quick
mhmmm this like whole game was just like
running things are going the others at
the lake and that's like [ __ ] far
chef is gonna cut get me all that that
beer yeah hell yeah what is that all the
way over there I don't [ __ ] know I
don't like the girls here not [ __ ] I
gotta go to this just in time town
No
now this all spent last fall Oh through
would crash all the [ __ ] time
yeah ticket right I game
great just right
okay let's take this match
alright i do here
okay okay so like I do is clear the
thing out
who's professor good feels I like him
hello Sarah
okay special special
oh my god built this shut hey no [ __ ]
room here I'll go through her side ok
good good hello about I love that
let's go let's go that's Davis that's
their vests Tom needs you keeps bugging
me about it uh-huh thank you the world's
a dangerous hey there you got the
platform your deadline tick-tock
tick-tock I'm waiting for the good news
I did it the platform and I filled in
the blank besides so this monstrosity
but there's three specialty I you find
those mm-hmm okay I'll get started yeah
the sooner the better not do you get
sure biometric scanner what the [ __ ]
okay I'm trying to there we go oh [ __ ] a
there we go let's do this skin-side
getting throughout sired baby I don't
know what [ __ ] dad [ __ ] onside
Jesus
okay we're all gonna get [ __ ] sec
well I'm gonna get sick that's cos go
hey man you dealt with the signal
intercept this thing will finally learn
about what you see ya okay let's do this
not sure how that was not bad so radio
station
scanner okay good good I can have all
these just go check my [ __ ] wow the
place you know I'm sad oh look at laughs
fuk raised like that song I like that I
like that I got to take a shower so I
got a [ __ ] do biometric scanner yeah
if I can take all of it um melter circ
what I know we [ __ ] have I ok
actually I'd you would actually I just
[ __ ] take all that because then I
could build defenses to which we dope
firstly build the [ __ ] though Shay's ass
chase s okay Karim of this okay and
Renee in one of this get good then we
also need me like a lot of power [ __ ]
this is 310 [ __ ] okay
this needs 20 this needs what
where the [ __ ] is this connect
nope we got it Scotland
now we need some defense all right to
good ya got
perp No
how can I ever go back to pamorah or any
doing a couple missions here once kind
of getting crazy you sure put back the
pain real quick
Tom want you for coming glad your women
okay okay okay hey got him human machine
interface to one hundred percent my data
indicates Mercer safe house has been
established agent Weatherby Thomas aka
tinker has delivered construction
material as promised reward dispensed if
you are available further assistance
could be used complainant okay cut cut
um let's get back here where's your safe
house
ok let's talk and tear this okay let's
whack in Dallas that's in this club had
I'd amazon make sure this is something
the same way there's no the rest of the
signal interceptor I got a [ __ ] cable
yeah yeah yeah
yep
no good cut gut toggle death tomorrow
hey there baby sexy
the institute is a huge under before we
can make any sense
you love me
hey treat there's a man or woman we're
not sure inside the Institute dozens of
sins Oh him their lives we don't know if
your plan works and your hmm i'll do my
best ok Tom encrypted a message for
Patriots eyes only once he sees it he'll
capture until you make contact and
probably after can you do that uh-huh
bring it right now you can do this stand
on the platform and i'll give you the
haram talk to me this frequency is only
going to work points
you know
so standstill that's this baby you
needed to contact patriot thank you guys
thank you do whatever you can to gain
their trust lies tell them what they
want to hear make up a cover story and
sell it come on I think I got
establishing lock on the Institute
Signet just get all the information you
can
about since about the Institute's plans
find their weaknesses if we can disable
or destroy the Institute we may have to
do it you just that Paula tape into any
terminal and Patriot will make contact
he has to that's all we got find them
nobody else can oh all right guys let's
do this